well good afternoon everybody thank you
very much for having me i'm really
excited to be here
today we are going to take a tour
of different machine learning algorithms
we're going to talk about the pros and
cons
and when to use them and we'll even look
at some use cases
we won't get too technical but there
will be a little bit of math for
reference and for fun
and just a little bit of code so you can
see how it's done
so i am a classically trained
statistician
and this is a lifelike image of me in
grad school
statisticians helped win world war ii
but we were never considered cool we
were
barely better than an actuary then
10 years ago we rebranded as data
scientists
and we became rock stars
this was the sexiest job of the 21st
century
at least according to harvard business
review
but that wasn't enough so now we do ai
and ai is so hot right now
you hear all about it so let's dive in
and define artificial intelligence
one particular definition i like is this
tweet from baron schwartz
he said when you're fundraising its ai
when you're hiring its ml
when you're implementing its linear
regression and when you're debugging
it's printf
this has nice linguistic implications
and it helps deflate the height
but i'm sure you're here for perhaps
more rigorous definitions
so i really like this diagram from a
book called deep learning
by goodfellow bengio incorval it's
a nested venn diagram and has sort of
become the successor to drew conway's
famous data science venn diagram
and you can see here that ai is this
all-encompassing
outer layer and some people have
described ai
as what's hard for computers but easy
for humans
i'm not a fan of that definition because
it's a moving goal post
in the 80s that was playing chess today
that's making restaurant reservations so
it keeps changing
but an important thing we can see here
is that machine learning
is the subset of ai and today
when people usually talk about ai they
really mean machine
learning so let's define machine
learning
also called ml
that takes us to another tweet i really
like this one really speaks to me
is from the 10 year challenge that was
popular a few years ago
shows in 2009 it was statistics in 2019
the exact same thing was machine
learning
we've been doing machine learning or
statistics whatever you want to call it
for hundreds of years we're just doing
it faster and bigger now
and if you call it ml you get paid more
so let's break down machine learning
into
three broad realms these are
reinforcement learning which is
semi-supervised learning
that's when you want to learn tasks like
how to play alphago
how to play pac-man basically how to
teach a computer to be a human in games
then you have unsupervised learning
which is mostly clustering
and that's when you want to group
observations together these groups go
together these observations go together
these observations go together it's
groupings and then there is supervised
learning
that's when you want to predict or
explain something
like a regression or classification and
today we are going to focus on
supervised learning
it's the most common form of machine
learning and it's really powerful
and supervised learning can be broken
down into different modes
these modes of machine learn supervised
learning are determined
by their outcome variable what you are
trying to model
let's say you're trying to model a
number a numeric
outcome this would be a regression
problem
these numeric outcomes as quantitative
outcomes could be
income could be altitude intensity
could be weight gain heart rate
the idea is that the model will compute
an average of the output
conditional on the inputs that's the
idea behind a regression
the next most common form is binary
classification
this is when you have two possibilities
like when lose
live die whether you get sicker or you
improve
something is true or false it's what
class something falls into
and this extends naturally to
multi-class classification
and the reason they're considered
different is because typically in
academic literature
you prove the two case first and the
multi-case it's easier to do the math
way and this multi-class problem
it could be that you are looking at a
suspicious trade
and you want to know if it's fraudulent
a fat finger mistake or bad judgment
or maybe have a picture of a vessel on
water and you want to determine if it's
a trawler or a speedboat or a fishing
boat or a skimmer or maybe
a patient has certain medical conditions
and you want to figure out the best
treatment for that patient what is
indicated
there's a number of different treatments
they can get which one should they be
classified as
while regression and classification are
by far the most common there's also
count data
this is when you have numbers of things
like the number of accidents
number of lawsuits number of children
number of deaths or number of people who
get sick
it's often overlooked and doesn't get
the glory of the other methods but it's
very important particularly in
healthcare
another important method in healthcare
is survival models this is when you look
at health over time
you might be interested in the
probability of someone dying or the
probability of a device failing like an
artificial hip
and you're generally looking at
proportional passages
then you have ranking this is when you
want to say how important
something is whether you're rating
treatments by effectiveness
or you're ranking chess players or
best-selling products
and these are just a subset of the
possible outcomes but they're very
common
outcomes and therefore very common
moments
separate but related are the main
machine running algorithms
each of these modes can be solved by
multiple algorithms
and each algorithm can solve multiple
nodes
it's not a one for one correspondence
today we're going to focus primarily on
regression classification and hazards
methods and a lot of them will be drawn
from personal experience at lantern
clinics
just some of the algorithms that are
available to you
are linear in logistic regression random
forest
survival models multi-level models time
series models generalized additive
moments
there's far more than i can list here
there are many many different ways to do
this
and remember each of these can solve
multiple modes
there is a lot we can do so let's start
at the top
generalized linear models glms
they're probably most commonly thought
of for regression problems
but they also work on classification and
count data
the idea is that you want to model the
outcome
with linear math in this case here it's
a regression
but again it also does classification
and counting we have our outcome which
is numeric
or could be classification problems
and we want to relate our inputs to it
so we generally fit a straight line now
it doesn't have to be an
actual straight line that's not what
linear means it's linear in a
mathematical sense
our goal is to find the intercept and
slope of this line
the intercept is a starting point
baseline
and the slope is the effect of the
income
on the output you model the
output as a linear combination of the
inputs
so you have your output y and your
multiple inputs x1
x2 xp each input has a certain effect
on the output those effects are the
betas beta 1 beta 2 beta p
these represent the effect or the weight
also called coefficients
have our data and we want to see how our
inputs relate to the outputs and we do
that
by solving for these betas which are the
slopes and intercepts
now we could solve this with a pencil
and paper and i have done that
i'd rather let the computer do that it's
much more efficient that way
and this generalizes to the two-class
classification problem
we have the same linear combination but
now our outcome is a logit
a log odds that is the odds of something
happening
the log of p over one minus p and this
does extend
into the multi-class classification
problem
another glm is dealing with count data
and here we have
log of lambda as their outcome and
lambda is a rate
so it's the same idea for all of these
the left-hand side is different
that's the generalized part and the
right-hand side is the same
that's the linear part it's a
generalized linear model
these are very useful
they're your baseline you just about
always start here
they're understandable they're fast
they're simple
but they're not without their drawbacks
the simplifying assumptions necessary
for these generalized linear models
don't always hold true it can be hard to
capture complex relationships between
inputs and outputs
failings aside they're very very useful
and they're often a go-to model at least
for the first model
one particular use case is if you're
trying to see
if a treatment improves condition
and you can reason about this in a few
different ways either they get better or
they don't
for instance cancer remission either get
rid of the cancer
or you unfortunately don't that's a
two-class classification that would be a
logistic regression
or we can look at it is how much does a
patient improve
like how much is cholesterol lowered in
that case that's a numeric outcome
that's a linear regression
and this is important for determining a
treatment's viability you need to know
how good it is before you let people use
it
and this model can be fit in r with one
line of code
using the glm function which is built
into r you call glm for
generalized linear model and you relate
your output y to your inputs x1 x2 x3
and this can do a linear model logistic
model poisson model and extensions of
those
and here we're doing binomial we say
family equals binomial
very common model very very common
especially in healthcare
and that's both for from a
pharmaceutical
context and device context another
common model for these problems
is cox proportional hazards it's like a
generalized linear model
for expected survival time you want to
estimate the time
till an event the event could be failure
the event could be
death and that time to the event
is associated with some input variables
so you're modeling probability of
surviving
or not surviving and that's your hazard
your hazard at time t which is the
opposite of survival
is modeled by h naught some
baseline hazard times the exponentiation
of that linear combination of our
x input variables and the goal here is
yet again
to model these betas in order to be able
to estimate
what someone's hazard is proportional to
some baseline
you would use cost proportional hazards
if you want to estimate the time to an
event
again not just survival but device
failure
if something is going to fail on you
you'd like to know when
and it works with censored data because
when you have a clinical trial
i'm telling you everyone in this room
here that a lot of you probably know
this
that people drop out of the trial they
haven't
died but they're not on the trial
anymore and you need to account for
their data no longer being present and
that's right censoring
cox ph works with that and it's commonly
understood
in its field
now what's wrong with a cost
proportional hazardous model
well it assumes proportionality
and this can break down with too many
inputs
it's a nice simplifying assumption but
doesn't always hold true anymore
not necessarily held true but nowadays
we're realizing it we have ways to get
around it
but it's all over the place like
measuring vaccine efficacy your risk of
acquiring a disease
the baseline risk would be the placebo
group because they haven't gotten the
vaccine
and then the vaccine group you would
follow up with them
at regular intervals or even irregular
intervals if you need
after they got vaccinated and there and
there are time
varying inputs and you want to see
how the vaccine is doing over time
now we all have one particular vaccine
on our minds right now
but other vaccines too you need to see
how long they last to know
if you need to get a booster shot before
you go on your next trip when people
start doing that again
so it's very important to be able to see
how long this lasts
the time to the event and you can fit
that
by using the survival package in r which
is built in and you call
cox ph instead of glm
and the outcome is now composed of
the time to an event well the current
time and whether or not an event has
occurred
which is passed into the serve function
that's modeled on
our three input variables and you can
figure out which impact input variables
affect your survival over time
and the pharmaceutical companies are
itching to use r for clinical trials
they would love to do this they're all
just waiting for somebody else to do it
first
and according to fda guidance e9
statistical principles for clinical
trials
no particular software is mandated but
the code does need to be well documented
which it should be along with the
versions and builds
so you could track the packages along
with the code inside git
and wrap it all in a docker container
and get some really reproducible results
a more modern version of proportional
hazards
is random survival force
we no longer need to assume proportional
hazards
instead we can fit a survival tree
a tree which is a survival tree is a
type of decision tree
is when you take your input data and
partition it recursively
into a series of buckets you get there
and you ask a bunch of yes no questions
of your data
is a number greater than a certain
amount is it less than a certain amount
we create these partitions and the
prediction from this tree
would be the average what falls into
prediction
trees are really nice because they
capture non-linearity
which is really prevalent in the real
world
but instead of having just one tree you
can have a forest of trees
you grow hundreds of trees randomly
and then you average them together this
is called
bagging bootstrap aggregated
each tree is built randomly and the
randomness comes into play both
at the rows and the columns when you're
about to fit a tree you randomly
sample the rows you're going to use and
that already makes the trees be a little
bit different from each other
but then as you're asking a series of
questions of your input data
at each time you're going to ask a
question you'll ask multiple questions
in a tree
instead of examining all of the
variables in your data
set to to decide what question to ask
you randomly sample a subset of those
questions
and then determine which question asks
based on that subset
so between these two levels of
randomness each tree is
going to be different and then you
average them all together
this is the formula for an ensembled
collection of survival trees it's
similar to a regular random forest but
this is specific to
survival trees so that inside the square
brackets
is the hazard ratio it is
the number of events at time lh divided
by the number at risk at time lh
and that's summed over a number of
conditions and that's
an individual tree and the outer sum is
averaging all the trees together
so this gives you your hazard at time
t you could do a regular random forest
for regression
classification or other problems but
this is a survival random forest
you would want to use a random survival
forest
because they give more powerful
predictions than linear models
and they're more flexible than cox
proportional hazards you no longer need
to assume proportionality
and they're fast each tree is fast to
grow
and you can grow all the trees in
parallel and they're easy to tune
and this will become important because
machine learning
is mostly just brute forcing your way
through tuning parameters
it's sad but that's true
the biggest problem of random forest is
that they are very hard to understand
we know how they work but not the
reasoning behind those choices
and that can make people uncomfortable
they don't know what's going on
a great use for this is personalized
risk assessment
let's say you need cancer treatment
you want to know what your individual
risks are as an individual patient
you don't want to be lumped under the
average you want to know your risk
and then you want to know the estimated
effects of the different treatments
for you you want to know how they are
going to affect you so you know
how aggressive your treatment should be
you don't want to go by the averages you
want to know do you need an aggressive
course of action
or a more mild course of action in a
random forest better helps predict
the effects for individual user users
and if you're that patient
you want it tailored to you and this is
a great use of machine learning to help
people
and again we can fit it with one line of
code
this time we use the random forest src
package
which stands for random forest for
survival regression classification
our outcome variable is a serve object
just like cox ph
we give it the time and whether or not
an event occurred by time
and our inputs and we get back a model
it's really nice let's turn our
attention
back to linearity for multi-level models
multi-level models are linear models
where the effects can vary by group
here we have multiple regression lines
and
each line has a different intercept in a
different slope
that's because the model learns from the
data as a whole
but then allows for nuance between
groups
this takes advantage of structure in the
data imagine
you have schools made up of students you
want to see the
overall quality of the school while
accounting for differences between
students
and this can handle many output types
regression count data classification
data many types
and we do this using bayesian methods
and that's such a hot topic right now
it's so popular
that the guardian recently referred to
it as an obscure math formula
that had stats twitter abuzz because
like they said this isn't obscure
but if you're not in the field this is
obscure to you
and we see here we have our outcome
variable and then this is a linear
combination of our inputs like we saw
for glms
except all of our betas our effects have
these
subscripts j sub i that's because
the effect will be different for each
grouping of data
multi-level models have a lot going for
them
they give better predictions than linear
models
and they allow for more complex
relationships
they can understand group dynamics which
is a really nice feature to have
and for longitudinal data they can
handle the non-independence
of repeated measures and that's really
important to
capture they're interpretable and they
even give you confidence intervals you
have a range of numbers
so what's wrong with them
they can be slow to fit because they
often use markov chain monte carlo
and they can be intimidating to people
getting started
but this intimidation can be worth it
let's say you're trying to predict
hospital readmissions
you are getting ready to discharge a
patient and you want to predict
if they're going to come back
you can't use a black box model because
you want to understand why
because we know why you can design
treatments and try to prevent it
and these multi-level models will take
into account the general population
trends
and also the individual characteristics
of the people
this builds a more complete picture and
ideally you can design interventions so
the patient doesn't return
and this personalized care that is
enabled by a multi-level model
following our trend we could use one
line of code
thanks to the r stand arm package from
andrew gellman's team
which has the function span glimmer
this allows us to model global effects
with group variations
our outcome variable y is modeled by x1
x2 and 3
and those all have global effects but
then
we see in the parentheses 1 plus x2 that
means the intercept is allowed to vary
by subject
and so is the effect of the second
variable so the first and third
variables
are measured from the global population
where the second variable
is measured from a global population
while picking up variations from
the group level data
there are other packages that can do
this like lme4 and
nlme but i'm a big fan of our stay in
arm because it's full beijing
somewhat related to this are generalized
additive models
gams these are linear models of
wiggliness
earlier these points had a straight line
going through through them
now we have a curvy line and the
technical term is wiggly it is a wiggly
line
and this is accomplished through a
mixture of penalized basis functions
you have your outcome variable y and
this can be regression or classification
or other types
and it is modeled on a linear
combination
of smoothing curves of the input x's
so each individual input or groups of
inputs even
have a smoothing curve fit onto them and
then
our outcome variable is modeled against
those smoothing curves
and that's how we estimate the effects
of the smoothing curves of our input
variables
and we want to again in the end estimate
those beams
and the smoothing curves are typically
thin plate splines or tensor products
but there are others as you can see a
lot goes into these
but you really want to use gams
because they give you better predictions
on linear models and they allow for more
complex relationships
they're more understandable than random
forests
and they give you confidence intervals
and they can even be used for
multi-level models
so what's wrong with them
i'm still searching these are magical
they can be a little bit slower than
other methods but they're so
powerful and they can be applied to so
many domains
including a novel recent use case
people are very interested in the daily
infection rates
of kobe or the daily hospitalization
rates or the daily
death rates and
generalized additive models fit a nice
smooth
curve to this data but we don't want to
look at the curve itself
by looking at the derivative of the
curve
we can tell if the infection rate or
other metrics
are accelerating or decelerating and
that's enabled because we have these
smooth curves which allows us to compute
a derivative
and knowing whether it is accelerating
or decelerating
can help impact policies and what we
should do and no for making headway or
falling behind
so gams can be very powerful they can be
very very helpful
and the most common way to fit a gam is
with
one line of code using the mgcv package
we call the gam function and we say our
outcome y
is modeled by smoothing curves of x1
x2 and x3 and that's all you would need
to do
you can specify other types of smoothing
curves you can specify structuring of
the data
and while again can actually pretty well
approximate the multi-level model
just by doing a grouped smoothing curve
you could actually fit complete
multi-level
generalized additive models using the
gam4 package
or the stan gam function from on
and they are just so powerful using so
many ways
i really think people should be using
more of them
turning to a completely different class
of model
is time series this is when
you have time dependent data
when you want to forecast into the
future based on previous time points
usually this is univariate
but it can also be multivariate and you
can see here it can even be used for
anomaly detection
now this will be some of the worst math
we are looking at today
we have that yt in the middle that's our
data but we're trying to model and
predict
we have the back shift operators the b's
and the superscripts the d's
telling us how far in the past to look
then you have the phi's and thetas
and those are the parameters we are
trying to estimate those are the effects
that we want to estimate
now this particular model is an arima
autoregressive integrated moving average
all represented right here in this
equation
there are other types of time series
like ets models
and gams yes you can use a generalized
additive model for time series
that's how powerful they are it's really
amazing
but arima models are perhaps the most
common type of time series
and one of the most powerful
time series models are useful when
you need to account for time and time is
everywhere
it's more places than you would realize
the issue with time series models
is that they are only meant for time
models
they're not meant to be used for
other types of models so that's the
biggest drawback
and they are not straightforward to
interpret
that's an issue that you might need to
deal with not knowing how they are but
you don't necessarily have a choice
yet and time is everywhere
let's say you're trying to decide if you
need to recall spinach
every day a certain number of people are
getting sick from spinach
and you keep track of that either on a
national level
a regional level a local level and you
collect this data over time
and you fit a model that predicts into
the future one day into the future
a week into the future two weeks into
the future and you make these
predictions and you get confidence
intervals
and then you check is the number of
sicknesses
outside the confidence interval bands
and maybe you need to say that more
people than expected are getting sick
for a certain number of days in a row
and at that point you'll make a recall
so time series methods can be crucial to
saving lives
and it's amazing how powerful they are
that based on the past
they can see into the future and say
when something seems out of whack
and that's anomaly detection and not for
nothing
but i've never seen pizza recalled it's
never hurt me
so maybe we should stop pushing spanish
so much and have more pizza
fitting a time series model can be done
in many ways but i like the fable
package from rob heinman's team
again we have one line of code the model
function
and it's very gener generically named
model
because you give it the data and then y
being which
column in the data set you want to use
and then you specify the type of time
series model
here it's in arima but you could do
other models like ets
and other ones and when you call it rima
it fits a number of different types of
arima models
all automatically for you and picks the
best one
this one line of code does so much work
for us that
we don't need to worry about it's really
really powerful
you've probably heard a lot about
deep learning also called neural
networks because they were loosely
inspired by the brain keyword
loosely you take your input data
and before you can relate it to your
output data you have to go through a
series of hidden states
you take your input layer
and you relate it to your first hidden
layer
you then relate that hidden layer to the
second hidden layer and the second layer
to a third hidden layer
which is finally related to your outputs
this is all the rage
there is so much height but i think it's
really just
extreme nonlinear modeling
you take your input x and you multiply
it by
a set of weights and this is an affine
transformation
a linear transformation you then call
a non-linear activation function on that
outcome
on that transformation and that's where
all the power
comes from the non-linearity because
there's so much nonlinearity in the
world
and that gets you your first hidden
layer you take that hidden layer
multiply it by a different set of
weights call a
nonlinear activation function and you
get your second layer
and you repeat this until you get to
your last layer
and you multiply that last layer by set
of weights and relate it to your outputs
you have all these weights which have
taken the place of our betas because
it's a different notation
and you need to estimate all these
weights
and there can be millions of them for a
fairly simple model you could have
millions of weights
and that could be very hard to estimate
and a lot of hard work
goes into estimating all those millions
of weights
and everyone wants to do deep learning
these days
because it gives you extremely good
predictions
especially for vision and language
there is a lot of hype
but it does give you strong predictions
for certain domains
the issue is that they are a complete
black
box you have no clue what's going on
inside
and they are slow to fit so slow that
you probably want to use a gpu
or more likely multiple gpus these can
be expensive to obtain if you can even
find one these days
and they consume a lot of electricity
and they are slow to tune there are so
many tuning parameters
you have the number of layers the size
of each of those layers
the batch size as you chunk through the
data
the ethics which are the number of
passes over the data
the learning rate the type of optimizer
the dropout percentage
batch normalization the type and amount
of regularization
this makes other machine learning models
look easy
but the results can be pretty amazing
looking at a brain apropos for neural
networks
let's say you have a scan and you want
to detect lesions in the brain
you could train a deep learning model to
identify and point those out to you
here in the colored areas there has been
great strides in radiology
if you want to detect cancer or
herniated discs
and it can also diagnose other elements
in the body
it's amazing what we can do with deep
learning these days if you have a large
enough training data set
and you can fit a good enough model but
deep learning is harder than what we've
seen
so far no more one-liners
this uses the torch package and we're
fitting a simple
network here with one layer of 32 nodes
in it
we have to choose our optimizer in this
case atom in the learning rate of 0.08
we make 200 passes over the data which
can be time consuming if you have a lot
of data
we make a forward pass on the model
essentially
it's the expectation step and then we do
a
back propagation to compute the
derivatives and we do this repeatedly
it's a lot of work and this is a simple
model and i've left out a lot of it i've
really condensed it
the two most popular frameworks
for fitting deep learning models are
torch
and tensorflow there are others but
these are the biggest
and they are all open source
everything we've seen today is open
source
that's free as in speech and as in beer
you can audit the code and you don't
have to pay for it
and this fosters innovation
it would be great for clinical trials to
be using more open source
it would lead to so much good in the
world
and you have to take care of the
community because open source brings
value both intrinsic and economic
a lot of the projects we do for the
department of defense
they insist that we use open source
tools and that we open source the work
we do
when it's appropriate that's how
important open source is
and if you benefit from the community
it's important to contribute back to the
community
if you want to learn more about open
source i run the
new york open statistical programming
group which is a meetup group and my
hack r
for learning about open statistics and
programming and data
also i run open source conferences in
new york and government related
come join us join the community be a
part of the community
contribute to the community and really
make a lot out of this community
it's so important and all this machine
learning including open source
where is all this being done who is
doing all this
i've been sharing first-hand knowledge
so far for this talk and we've helped a
lot of customers
this is just a small subset of our
customers the ones that
let me mention them publicly
at these companies we various different
types of machine learning
with carfax we held model car prices
macmillan had us forecast book sales
and the minnesota vikings brought us in
to do their draft picks a few years ago
and our draft days tomorrow's we're all
very excited for them because we
implemented hundreds of machine learning
models to help them get the best draft
in their draft class
and we've done many projects of
pharmaceuticals
but unfortunately none of them would let
me list who they are
which is a shame because we've done some
really fascinating projects
some examples which i can gloss over and
not mention the companies
we helped model the variability in the
manufacturing of drugs
so you can know how to make them more
efficiently we forecasted weekly
prescriptions
and we helped another one integrate open
source into their research
and those are just a few examples of
what we've done for pharmaceutical
companies
and these are just a few examples of
companies we've worked with
we can't name all of our companies but
we've worked in so many other industries
ranging from manufacturing to
pharmaceuticals to food producers
banking defense
legal politics finance insurance
we're a small company and we've touched
all these industries imagine what
is out there imagine what's being done
so to draw down on everything we have
seen today
machine learning can model many types of
data there are many modes
whether that is numeric data
classification
count data survival rates rankings and
remember the outcome type
dictates the mode once you've determined
your mode
you then choose your model and there are
many model types generalized linear
models
tree based models bayesian methods deep
learning
just to name a few of them and each of
these model types
can solve multiple outcome types
and there are countless use cases
whether you want to look at treatment
efficacy or you want to detect bad
products or anomaly detection or image
recognition
there are so many things you can do
you're only limited by your imagination
and you can do all these things in just
about
any industry whether that's government
the private sector
academic non-profit everyone can use
this the key is knowing when to apply
which model
knowing the right method for a given
problem
and knowing when the gains are worth the
investment
sometimes simpler is better and
faster so hopefully now you have a
better sense of what to look for
thank you very much